l'ONG one qui lutte contre l'extrême
pauvreté et qui a été confondé par Bono
du groupe
U2 au total 55 jeunes ambassadeurs
s'engagent et se mobilisent pour lutter
contre l'extrême pauvreté et les
inégalités dans le monde et nous sommes
ce soir avec l'un de ses ambassadeurs
l'ambassadeur yvelinois Guillaume légère
bonsoir bonsoir alors tout d'abord
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter un
peu plus ce qu'est cette ONG one
invitation sur votre plateau ce soir
donc one vous l'avez dit c'est une ONG
internationale de plaidoyer donc c'est
pas une lettre de terrain c'est une ONG
qui va essayer de sensibiliser de
l'opinion publique et aussi les
personnalités politiques sur la hausse
malheureuse de l'extrême pauvreté depuis
les années 90 depuis maintenant quelques
années l'extrême pauvreté remonte et
c'est justement pour lutter contre ces
inégalités croissantes que One a été
fondée donc en 2004 mais c'est bien de
le programme des jeunes ambassadeurs qui
lui fait ses 10 ans cette année donc
voilà vous faites effectivement vos dix
ans cette année quel est le programme
quelles sont les actions qui sont
prévues pour ces 10 ans alors de
nombreuses actions vous vous en doutez
bien on va essayer de réunir à cette
occasion les tous les jeunes
ambassadeurs qui sont passés par One
Lady dernières années ce moment de
cohésion va forcément être pour nous un
moment charnière pour remettre de
remettre un nouvel élan un nouveau
souffle à la lutte contre les inégalités
donc cette année plusieurs actions vont
être prévues le programme est chargé on
y reviendra plus tard mais la France va
accueillir un sommet en juin prochain
promis par Emmanuel Macron lors de la
COP 27 pour nouer un nouveau pacte
financier avec les pays les moins
avancés et on développements afin qu'il
puisse être plus résilient face aux
nombreuses crises que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
tout de suite que qu'est-ce qui va se
passer concrètement avec le président de
la République voilà donc on le sait
aujourd'hui avec la guerre qu'on a aux
portes de l'Europe
la crise du covid dont nous ressortons à
peine et la crise aliment la montée des
prix beaucoup de pays qui sont très peu
responsables de ces enjeux géopolitiques
en subissent les pires conséquences
c'est notamment le cas en Afrique on le
retrouve la majorité des pays les moins
avancés donc l'objectif de ce sommet
donc promis lors de la Coop 27 à charnel
shake à l'automne dernier va voir pour
but de
renouer voilà un nouvel élan signé un
nouveau pacte avec ces pays-là ça
passera par une réforme des banques
multilatérales de développement comme
tout simplement la Banque mondiale ou la
Banque africaine de développement on
passera aussi par une restructuration de
la trajectoire de l'aide publique au
développement français qui est le
principal outils financier pour aider
les projets de résilience de ces états
en développement et les moins avancés
en tout cas voilà il faudra vraiment
nouer un partenariat entre les États
économiques du Nord qui peuvent se
permettre des efforts avec les États du
Sud qui sont dans la panade depuis
quelques temps maintenant et du coup
pour devenir ambassadeur de cette ONG
one vous avez suivi des formations pour
aller à la rencontre des décideurs
politiques et des décides politiques
parce que c'est vraiment au cœur de
l'action de l'ONG exactement c'est une
jette plaidoyer alors forcément il y a
un volet formation voilà comment
s'exprimer des gens en public arriver à
convaincre et peser dans des
négociations vous l'avez dit avec des
personnalités politiques on a été amenés
l'année dernière à l'occasion des
élections présidentielles à rentrer des
chefs de partis politiques des chefs de
fil de la majorité et après les
élections législatives des
parlementaires donc voilà on leur
parlait surtout la trajectoire à venir
lors du second quinquennat de Monsieur
Macron de l'aide publique au
développement ça a fonctionné ça c'est
bien mis en place
pour revenir sur la formation tout ça
nous apprend pas ça s'apprend surtout
dans le tard il faut il faut beaucoup
s'entraîner et plaidoyer pour arriver à
convaincre mais oui on a des avancées la
loi du 4 août qui a été signée en 2021 a
pour but de revaloriser l'aide publique
au développement français mettre en
place des commissions d'évaluation de
notre aide pour savoir si elle est
efficace pour savoir si on est bien
légitime sur le terrain et que notre
action a un impact on a plus de 70
députés qui ont signé notre pétition à
l'automne dernier pour s'assurer que la
public au développement va bien
atteindre le seuil des 07% du revenu
national brut d'ici à 2027 c'était un
engagement d'Emmanuel Macron lors de sa
précédente campagne pour l'instant on
est en retard donc on est là pour faire
du back office et remettre les bouchées
doubles pour rappeler à nos
parlementaires ceux qui le doivent
promulguer dans notre législation et
alors c'est la deuxième année
consécutive que vous êtes ambassadeur
dans les Yvelines pour l'ONG one j'ai
envie pourquoi en fait cet engagement
d'où vous vient cet engagement depuis
tout petit j'ai toujours été sensible
aux injustices et c'est vraiment un
voyage juste après mon baccalauréat en
Mongolie où j'ai pu faire un projet de
développement dans les stèles Mongols un
projet de permaculture où j'ai eu ce
déclic je me suis dit ok Guillaume il
faut que tu aides comme tu peux les
autres et que tu te que tu combattes les
inégalités injustice en fait voilà je me
définis souvent comme un soldat du bon
sens et One est un très bon une très
bonne ONG de plaidoyer pour ça parce que
avec ses moyens donc ces jeunes
d'ambassadeurs on arrive quand même à
des grosses avancées par la suite vous
êtes étudiant en parallèle ça vous prend
beaucoup de temps de d'être ambassadeur
dans les Yvelines oui bah tout à fait
quand on est vraiment engagé forcément
on ne compte pas forcément le temps
qu'on y passe d'ailleurs je vais vous
faire une petite confidence désolé papa
maman mais j'ai séché un cours à la
Sorbonne pour pouvoir venir ici ce soir
vous parler mais oui forcément c'est
c'est un engagement personnel mais après
il permet de découvrir tellement de
choses d'en apprendre sur ce qui se
passe véritablement dans notre monde
aujourd'hui et pour moi ça a vraiment un
sens cet engagement chez one et par la
même vue que je fais des études de
développement à Paris et ben c'est
complètement complémentaire avec ma
formation universitaire donc là dans
l'autre les deux se complètent et bien
merci beaucoup Guillaume légère d'être
venu un plateau avec nous pour nous
parler des 10 ans du programme
ambassadeur de cette ONG on